c'est au pied du python des neiges dans
le Circle de silaos que je vous emmène
aujourd'hui pour parler de broderie la
broderie de silaos une tradition dont la
réputation a aujourd'hui largement
dépassé nos frontières et qui se
transmet depuis plusieurs générations
marielcian tcher fait partie de la
quarantaine de brodeus qui perpétuent
cette tradition avec une certaine
adaptation au modernisme et à
l'obligation commerciale et
touristique madame tch depuis combien de
temps vous faites de la broderie de la
broderie effectivement ça fait depuis ma
jeunesse
et cétait un
travail de mère en fille à l'époque que
mes
parents ma grand-mère ma mère et puis je
les voyais travailler ça me plaisait et
puis finalement c'est qu'après bon je me
suis dit pourquoi pas me lancer dans ce
genre de choses là quoi parce que bon
c'est vrai quand j'avais mes parents mon
père lui il on avait pas tellement TR le
moyen de de continuer les études et tout
et puis je je me suis lancé et ça m'a
plu et jusqu'à présent je suis très je
suis fière quand même d'avoir pris ce
créneau là c'est votre grand-mère
principalement qui est à l'origine de de
cet amour pour la broudderie donc
pour c'est une la bourderie c'est
d'origine bretonne et c'est une dame
elle est venue sur sur la Réunion
c'était une jeune demoiselle s'app
angelolif
et comme à
l'époque il y avait pas grand chose à
faire dans le CIRC c'était vraiment elle
s'est mise à broder et puis quand elle
savait ce qu'elle faisait et tout elle a
transmis son savoirfaire à toutes les
dames
de et par la
suite ma grand-mère fait
partie ma maman faisait partie et
maintenant donc ça a été vraiment un
travail d' quoi au départ c'est des fils
donc c'est le tissu qu'on achète chez un
grossiste
vir je sais pas d'où ça vient mais c'est
du lin c'est un travail c'est un tissu
de qualité donc on achète notre tissu
après la base du tissu c'est le les fils
tirés ça s'appelle le traçage après le
traçage c'est les fils lancés et puis
après les fils lancés donc c'est la
brerie qui viennent sur les fils qu'on
lance est-ce que c'est la même broderie
ou chacune vous avez une
originalité personnellement chacune
elles ont leur
leur leur techniqueoi quoi de faire bon
moi j'ai j'essaie d'améliorer un petit
peu dans les encadrements dans parce
qu'à l'époque c'était plutôt les grosses
pièces c'estàdire na service drap et
ainsi de suite mais comme c'est long à
faire c'est un travail qui demande
beaucoup beaucoup de temps à le faire
donc c'est pour ça que je préfère faire
des petites choses parce queun touriste
les touristes qui arrivent chez nous
pour ramener des petits souvenirs c'est
quand même mieux qu'avoir des grosses
pièces est-ce qu'il y a possibilité
d'évoluer est-ce qu'au fur et à mesure
vous
faites le travail au niveau des PO au
niau des motifs oui moi person j'essaie
de on dit toujours qui cherche j'arrive
à trouver vraiment des bonnes choses à
faire pour l'instant je je me suis visée
pour l'encadrement
ensuite j'aurai aussi des cartes
postales une petite c'est des petits
souvenirs vraiment pas chers pas l' à
ramener et je crois que c'est des beaux
souvenirs que qu touriste qui passe de
ramener un petit quelque chose comme ça
ça ça vaut la peine la broderie de Cos
c'est magnifique c'est fin c'est un
travail très très admirable mais ça a la
réputation aussi d'être très cher est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord quand on dit que
c'est très cher ou oui c'est vrai que ça
revient un petit peu cher mais quand on
regarde aussi le le coûp de de du tissu
quand on regarde le tempint qu'on s'y
met quand on regarde aussi tout
l'ensemble quoi donc quand on voit euh
qu'on passe des heures et des heures
pour faire un petit Napon quand une
journée ou de jours ou 3 jours ou une
semaine pour faire donc c'est vrai que
les choses à la main le travail à la
main tout fait à la main c'est vrai que
ça revient un petit peu cher c'est un
petit peu cher si vous voulez mais c'est
des choses c'est inusablees c'est ça
reste hein ça reste des années et des
années mais parce que moi je vois moi
j'ai un drap je me j'ai brodé un drap
quand j'étais jeune je m'en sers et je
crois que je ne regrette pas d'avoir
d'avoir fait ça pour moi parce que mes
filles elle va pouvoir avoir
ce ce travail là bon à vie quoi vous
avez parlé de vos enfants tout à l'heure
vous avez dit que vous avez deux filles
ce ça oui j'ai deux filles est-ce
qu'elle brode veut ma première fille
peut-être si elle était à la Réunion
elle aurait eu peut-être le sentiment de
d'apprendre de reprendre le relais mais
comme elle a visé autre
chose donc je ne peux pas non plus
euh je préfère enfin c'est pas dire que
je préfère qu'elle est partie non c'est
pas cette question mais pour moi je je
préfère quand même qu'elles ont trouvé
un autre créneau parce que c'est quand
même il faut aimer il faut aimer et vous
pensez que actuellement c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de demander aux jeunes
d'apprendre ce métier de vivre de ce
métier c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible non parce que bon déjà bon je
j'ai je suis inscrite à la Chambre des
Métiers et puis après quand j'ai vu que
c'était
euh c'était c'était pas possible parce
que bon à l'époque j'avais mon mari qui
on était j'étais soudé quoi il était là
lui il faisait son travail moi j'avais
le mien et c'était quand même un peu
plus organisé maintenant je suis toute
seule
donc je ne peux plus assumer beaucoup de
choses quoi mais ce que je je fais
j'essaie de tenir le le plus possible
mais je me suis inscrite par la suite à
la Chambre de commerce pour que je
puisse avoir un petit plus parce que je
ne peux pas vivre que de que de la
broderie quoi bonjour salut ça va toi
venez monsieur
dameà quand les touristes passent est-ce
que c'est plus pour admirer regarder ou
il y en a qui achètent ça dépend il y en
a qui qui les admir il y en a qui les
achètent pour offrir au aux gens qui
parce que bon c'est vrai en artisanat à
la Réunion il y en a quand même des
belles choses il y en a des belles
choses mais à touriste qui passe sur
silaos quand on parle les broderies
c'est quand même les broderies c'est
quand même un atout pour pour silaos
quoi c'est quand même un travail d' où
les gens
recherchent ces qualités là quoi le
moment de l'accueil ça dépend des jours
ça dépend des jours parce qu'il y a des
jours que je ne peux pas travailler puis
recevoir en même temps donc
a des JS je puisseoir group termin vous
avez une boutique j'ai mon atelier et
puis j'ai ma boutique
ù que les gens viennent pour voir et
puis par l'occasion si les gens veulent
acheter des petits souvenirs ils peuvent
éventuellement acheter sur place ça
vient tout à fait naturellement ça vient
bon c'est aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
faire le PA que jeis pa que c'est des
gens de la Réunion qui viennent voir
tourist réun j'ai des touristes qui
viennent un petit peu partout
l'extérieur mais j'ai aussi mes
touristes de la Réunion qui sont très
gentils qui m'ont vraiment soutenu dans
mes moments difficiles que j'avais
tellement besoin et je tiens aussi de je
tiens aussi à cette occasion pour les
remercier parce que c'est vrai que si
j'étais si j'étais pas entouré je crois
que j'aurais laissé tomber et ça aurait
été dommage et c'est des petites cstal
justement donc c'est posé sur une carte
et son très cont moi je ce
matin
ch ramener où il y a quelques jeunes qui
qui qui viennent apprendre et euh c'est
c'est quand même c'est bien c'est ça se
trouve où sur silaos d'accord voilà ce
sont des jeunes qui veulent apprendre le
métier qui viennent ici en St à l'époque
il y
avait donc il avait des pendant 2 ans il
faisait un
stage au musée à l'école la maison La
Borderie et et maintenant je sais pas
s'il y en a sils font encore des des
stages quoi je sais pas s'ils en on
encore des stagiaires vous faites pas
partie de l'association non je fais pas
partie de leur association je me suis
mise par mon compte personnel et je
crois
que comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
j'avance petit à petit je reste petit je
pour l'instant je suis encore petit mais
au fur et à mesure je crois que ça va
grandir à part le salon de l'artisanat
est-ce que vous avez eu possibilité
d'exposer vos
travaux euh euh à silaos ou ailleurs à
silaos oui il y a le il y a l'office du
tourisme très gentil d'ailleurs les
hôtels sont vraiment des
elles sont admirables admirables parce
que bon elles nous envoie du monde
aussi et puis de temps en temps ils font
dans l'année une exposition artisanale
pour c'est la journée de l'accueil voilà
c'est à l'office du tourisme ici à
SOS et ben le trage s mesuré c'est vous
prenez voilà vous prenez un centimètre
et vous mesurez de là à là c amétier
vraiment c'est quand même un petit peu
c'est un peu long si vous voulez mais
quand on aime son travail on ne cherche
pas la difficulté moi j'ai dis quand je
me suis inscrite à la Chambre des
Métiers j'avais ce besoin en moi parce
que je dis
que on le travail déjà c'est ça devient
très très
rare on se demande souvent des fois nous
femmes on aimerait être aussi partir
vers l'extérieur mais il y a des moments
on pas moi je suis pas aidé je suis pas
aidé bon j'ai
j'ai ouvert mon entreprise par mes
propres moyens vraiment tout départ
c'était petit mais on s'est dit que avec
les touristes que je recevais pour moi
c'était quand même une porte ouverte
quoi parce que si on veut moi j'aurais
j'aurais pu être comme tout le monde
mais je voulais partir vers
l'avant avancer et quand on avance je
crois
que par la suite on se dit tiens j'ai
bien fait d'avancer parce que il faut
jamais regarder derrière faut toujours
avancer dire donc si c'est pas
aujourd'hui ça va être demain et c'est
pas demain donc ça va être aprèsdemain
mais je crois qu'en parlant comme ça on
y arrive avoir un
but ensable imagination et créativité
pour que la broderie de silaos continue
à faire partie du patrimoine artisanal
du cirque et de notre île tout
entière